[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
in broadcast
on thursday july 15th i'm kate andrews
the spectators economics editor
and your host this week on this week's
show
social distancing ends and mass events
get back underway from monday
but with brits still encouraged to wear
masks and the pm urging caution
it's hardly the freedom day that we were
once promised
in this week's cover piece for the
magazine fraser nelson wonders whether
or not boris johnson has lost his
liberalism
he'll join us first and then we'll speak
to the journalist and spectator
contributor patronella wyatt
who knows the prime minister well
infections might be high but deaths are
staying relatively low
we'll speak to professor tim spector the
principal investigator on the zoe app
a self-reporting symptom tracker for
kova 19
who says we're in a new phase of the
pandemic
our home team will give a politics
update i'll be speaking to james forsyth
and isabel hardman
about the cut to the foreign aid budget
then we'll look to cuba
where protests have sparked questions
over whether or not the socialist regime
can survive
i'll be speaking to chatham house's
chris sabatini
and finally toby young was at the euros
final last weekend
and says in his column this week that it
was like a scene from a disaster movie
he'll tell us why all that to come in
the next hour but before we get going if
you enjoy what we do on spectator tv
then subscribe to our youtube channel
for free
click the button at the bottom of this
video and then tap the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode
and why not subscribe to the spectator
magazine too and take advantage of our
new special offer
we're giving you 10 weeks of the
spectator in print and online
for the price of one with a free bottle
of pims worth 25 pounds thrown in there
too
so that's 10 weeks of the spectator with
the magazine delivered to your door
and bottle of pims all for just four
pound 95.
hurry though this offer ends on monday
the 19th of july
just go to spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer to take it up
now first we're promised freedom day on
monday but it looks like people will
still be encouraged to wear masks
and venues will now be asking for
vaccine certificates
in this week's cover piece fraser nelson
looks at the pm's alarming flight from
liberalism
he joins me now fraser thanks for
joining me
in this week's cover story you lament
the prime minister's eroding love of
liberty
what's changed well if you talk to boris
johnson not much has changed he hasn't
really said
that he's changed his mind and that all
the arguments used against tony blair's
id
cards in 2004 are now passe and
he now agrees with tony blair with the
need for a vaccine passport that's
what's happened but that's not what he
is saying and now boris johnson if you'd
asked me to define him as a politician
i would have said he was a liberal
before he is a conservative
he's adopted some although throughout
his career he's been actually quite
consistent
in what he said and what he's written
his columns when he was doing my job
editing the spectator it was a
great beacon of liberalism a champion
the idea that societies are stronger if
people are left to do
and what they want with their lives and
but
what's changed is that in the pandemic a
lot of people's beliefs have been
challenged
a lot of people's belief in liberal
democracy has been challenged it's been
said that all of this
attention to privacy to individual
rights to basic liberty
has put us in a weak position compared
to the more authoritarian asian
countries who did a little better job
in handling covid so you see now a lot
of people not just in politics thinking
well
maybe it would be better if we had more
controls over our lives more
curtailments over liberty
you see opinion pools very much in favor
of lockdown some people wanting to keep
locked down
way beyond the covered period so there
is a shift in the mood
and a shift in government policy but
what concerns me is it's not being
explained
we heard from michael gove back in
december that he had no plans to
introduce maxine passports he didn't
know anybody who did
we heard from nadine zahawi the vaccine
minister but there would be no vaccine
passports they were a bad
idea we heard from number 10 but it
would be discriminatory to have vaccine
passports
and yet what do we see now in the
so-called freedom day preparations
we have um plans to invite encourage
and even perhaps threaten companies who
do not
use vaccine passports so we're getting
theaters who are going to be saying
they're going to follow what the
government
says and demand that people are
vaccinated
before they get their theater ticket and
that could be just the start
previously in this country you could go
wherever you wanted you could work
wherever you wanted whether anybody
asking about your health
status that is about to change and not
because of vote of parliament
because of some kind of um footnote
in plans that have been described to us
rather ironically as
freedom day it's not just with covid you
say in your cover piece but rather it
fits a trend
boris once attacked the introduction of
id cards adamantly and as you say
he's now the one ushering in vaccine
passports having once argued
passionately that free adult should be
able to make free decisions
he's now advocating for a nanny state
bringing in junk food ban
on ads two for one bands and more what
could possibly be his justification
well when he went down with kovids he
did say afterwards that changed his mind
about
health and safety ism about nanny state
he did think
it was time for government to do more to
get people to slim down
don't be a fatty in your 50s that was
his advice
and since then it's funny he ran for the
tory party leadership saying that
he would not be putting a tax on on
milkshakes
but since then he has basically um
banned three for two offers for meals
he has um said that restaurants
should be putting calorie counts on each
of the menu
items these are things which he would
have had disparaged
as nanny's statism gone mad only a few
years ago
so he is on a political journey and i
think with the vaccine passports that
journey has gone a lot further than a
lot of us
had thought only a few weeks ago it's
been imagined that vaccine passports
were not going to be deployed
because boris johnson still thought that
if you have to produce
a papers please society then there is
something fundamentally unbritish about
that
it seems he's changed his mind but we
haven't really heard from him
why fraser in your piece you write that
in a rather orwellian turn
freedom day on the 19th of july means
freedom for some
not for all specifically in relation to
these vaccine passports
now a few weeks ago you took the
government's argument for delaying
freedom day on good faith
you said thinking it might empower them
to really restore
freedom just a few weeks down the line
do you feel like they've let you down
no not really i don't think i was naive
about what governments
would do here i think what's happened
with the vaccine passports is simple
but they've seen how fast the delta
variance spread the reason i was
sympathetic to the government delaying
freedom day was i didn't think they'd
adjusted for the delta
variant they needed to unlock telling
people as they are now doing their cases
are going to surge
they hadn't got any of that ready back
in the day and if we had unlocked back
then it would
have been seen as a great disaster
because cases would have surged
now they've recalibrated but they've
worked out but to get to herd immunity
say you might need 85 percent of the
population including children
if you don't want to vaccinate children
they need to do a lot better job
vaccinating the adults
and if the adults are not coming forward
to be vaccinated
then they need to be basically less not
mince words you
need to be harassed until they do get
vaccinated
so that's what's brought about the
change in heart looking at the delta
variant and thinking
they need far higher vaccine penetration
amongst the grown-ups
if they're going to avoid vaccinating
children again
i just picked this up on the grapevine i
would far rather if the government was
explicit about this rationale
and told people why soon people like me
and employers like me
might be asking people like you kate to
give me proof that you've had your
vaccine
and if you don't that might be entering
a difficult conversation about whether
those who've got no jab
should also have no job are you worried
at all that
it only took about a week for the new
health secretary sacha javits language
to change
he started out saying that moving
forward as we got out of these
restrictions that move would be
irreversible
now he's been saying when aston in the
commons
and that he he might bring restrictions
back if the data called for it
and do you feel like the 19th of july is
really freedom day and are you worried
about them leaving
quite maybe a big gap in the door open
for restrictions to come back in this
autumn
i certainly wouldn't call it freedom day
for a start freedom is not within the
gift of government to give
to people this freedom ought to be
something far more absolute so i don't
like the idea we should be
clapping our hands and thanking uh big
brother for giving us more of our
our liberty back that's just the way i'm
i'm a
sort of old-fashioned adam smith liberal
that's just the way
i see society i think sasha javid is
changing his language because you can
never
say never any politician should know
that of course he would like to think
he's irreversible but there's a hostage
to fortune
if he were to continue that language
um but overall i think the government's
my my big problem again comes down to
lack of debate and lack of transparency
i imagine that sahaja yoga would love to
abolish vaccine passports as soon as he
could
but right now he doesn't feel able to
that's because
we haven't yet had a debate as to what
these vaccine passports do
if you're double jabs you you've still
got a part according to public health
england a 20
chance of catching the var the virus you
can still give it to people
if you're double jabbed so can you
really say that a theater full of fully
vaccinated people
is entirely safe and covered you can't
do
do vaccine passports make a material
impact on the spread of the virus as
that's why we're doing it
or are we doing it simply because we
want to find ways of making life more
difficult
for those who have not done what the
government wants and taken the vaccine
and then i then what about those who've
got good reason not to take
the vaccine what about those who forever
reason
do you actually again is it on me is it
on the government to decide what's a
good reason
and what's not do we believe in this
country that there is such a thing
as the right to know to take the vaccine
once upon a time when we thought herd
immunity could be achieved with
two-thirds of the population
that thought people thought no problem
you easily get that level
now we've got 90 of adults with
antibodies
but that is not enough for herd immunity
so now we're into this difficult
position with very difficult questions
all i'm saying in the cover piece we
should be openly debating those
questions
there should be a debate in parliament
and a vote as to whether vaccine
passports really is the route
which we want the country to go down
fraser thanks for talking to us
so what was the prime minister like back
in the days when he was a fierce
advocate for liberty
i'm joined now by patronella wyatt who
worked at the spectator when boris
johnson was editor and who knows his
character well
petronella thanks for joining us today
fraser wonders in his cover piece
whether the pm has
lost his liberalism do you think he has
yes i do
i think the problem with boris is that
um not that he doesn't have a series of
beliefs
because he does and they are
instinctively liberal
but they're not deeply held enough
they're not so
deeply held that they can't be
sacrificed to what he sees as
political expediency and the continuing
prosperity of boris johnson i think
unfortunately his greatest belief
is in himself so um he's not
a conviction politician and
he's very much an opinion
poll sort of prime minister
and he yo-yos all over the place um
because he thinks
this is what please this is what is
going to please people
um and i think that's a terrible
weakness in a prime minister because you
have to have a consistent
policy you have to have the moral
courage to
stand up for what you believe in but i i
don't think going back to his beliefs
yes he has a history of expanding
liberal beliefs but i don't think
his beliefs are terribly profound i
don't think he's a terribly profound
person and yet he's spoken
with such a fierce passion and defense
of liberty in the past i mean he used to
rail
against things like id cards which is
now
um seems like a much lighter policy
compared to a vaccine passport
he said in the telegraph in 2004 that if
an official ever was asked to see
an id card he would take it out of his
wallet and physically
eat it you're suggesting though that
even putting forward those robust
defenses of liberalism
the polls now matter more to him
yes um but also remember that he was
put for he put forth these views in
articles
um and his articles were always very
entertaining
and there was always an element of
exaggeration
uh he would not have actually eaten his
id
card um i honestly can't see him doing
that boris is a performer
and performers will exaggerate
and performers are more interested in
the performance
than in in beliefs
because honestly if his liberal beliefs
were so
strongly held he wouldn't be doing this
he he would not be thinking about
backs and passports which is so coercive
um he wouldn't be saying
to businesses and offices well um
you don't have to wear a mask but if you
don't we will force you to
i mean he's not acting like a liberal
conservative
why isn't he because his liberal
conservatives beliefs aren't that strong
and his desire to stay in power is
stronger
of course that masked mandate is lifting
although the pm's
talk in recent days has been extremely
cautious and they seem to have done
quite a few
uh u-terms at least in terms of the
rhetoric about how they're going to
treat freedom day
pacinelli you knew boris johnson when he
worked at the spectator
what was he like then um
he was a very genial person um
but you would notice that he would say
different things to different people
make them different promises
because he's a people pleaser and that
would get him into a lot of trouble
and in the end you end up pleasing
nobody and this is
what he's been like as a politician he
sees opinion
polls which may or may not be accurate
claiming that
a significant number of people want to
keep going with restrictions but some of
these polls are dubious like the ipsos
maury because the ft
took it apart and
and this is why he he sort of does this
um but it's not it's not a sustainable
policy
because it's not leadership i mean going
back to
his personality at the spectator
he did have a tendency when it came to
politics to agree with
one person on the right and then 10
minutes later
in another room agree with one person on
the left
um and that's just boris because boris
wants to be liked
um but it's not a great trait in a
in a leader especially during a crisis
um are we getting to the crux of it in
the sense that boris johnson really
supports liberalism in the sense that he
likes to be able to do what he wants
and but then when it comes to something
like a national emergency where the
government has
you know huge amounts of power over our
lives
he's still quite he quite likes to be
able to to do what he
wants the problem is that we all have to
follow along with it too
yes i would say that's a pretty good
summation
um he wants to do what he wants um
so he will not observe social distancing
and when we saw that at wembley we saw
that
at the g7 summit um but
he will force the rest of us to do it
um and you get a you've got to bury them
enough
situation with this government and
that that is very dangerous for a
politician that could come back to bite
him because he's now
very he's annoying his core base
immensely because i speak to mps who are
getting emails from their constituents
all the time saying what's going on this
is not a conservative government
this is a kind of socialist status
government
and it's all very well for boris to do
what he
wants in number 10 and go to parties in
which they all do
and and not wear masks but um
you cannot flaunt this as he does in
photo opportunities
and then you know expect um the british
people
to to mask up well
last question petronella if another
prime minister
were in his place and boris were still
writing his columns
what do you think he'd be saying about
the current restrictions and freedom day
on the 19th of july oh yeah he'd be
um he'd be saying that the current
restrictions were appalling infringement
of freedom
he'd be quoting pericles of athens he'd
be quoting benjamin franklin
um he'd be pouring scorn on
himself as it were um i mean if he was
still the old boris
because i i think the old boris has sort
of disappeared
power has done something to him um
he would be hating himself as prime
minister
petronella thanks for joining us on
spectator tv
remember we've got a new special offer
if you subscribe to the spectator
magazine today get
10 weeks of the spectator in print and
online
for the price of one with a free bottle
of pims worth
25 pounds thrown in there too that's 10
weeks of the magazine delivered to your
door
and a bottle of pims all for just 4
pound 95.
hurry though this offer ends on the
so-called freedom day
19th of july if you want to take it up
go to spectator
dot co dot uk forward slash tv offer
so we have a watered down freedom day on
the 19th
does the data justify this joining me
now is professor tim spector principal
investigator on the zoe app
tim thanks for joining me to start there
are more than 42
000 cova cases reported on wednesday but
the rate at which these cases are rising
is trending downwards and the number of
people dying from the virus
is far lower than what we were
experiencing in previous waves
are you convinced that the link between
cases and severe illness from this virus
has been sufficiently broken
i believe the link has been
not completely broken but virtually
broken so that
the rise in cases is is no longer
seen in deaths and hospitalizations and
i think we're moving into this a new era
in in covid in that regard and
i think we need to start looking at
other parameters of
the infection rather than this
uh out of date look at
deaths in particular which isn't really
helping us
so you've talked about entering this new
phase of the pandemic
and your focus is on new problems of
cold symptoms and also long covered
so what do you think we should be
focusing on now i think we need to
realize that we're gonna
we're still gonna get large numbers of
people infected
uh the data from the zoe app today
is is actually showing that we're
crossing over into having more people
with infections having had a vaccine
than
unvaccinated for the first time and so
this is very much a new era
in the disease as in a way the
unvaccinated population is like running
out of susceptible people
who haven't been infected and they were
mainly the younger ones
and we're getting back this this larger
group of people have been vaccinated
which small proportion
are getting a mild disease and
this means that
the idea that vaccination is a complete
cure if you like for the diseases has to
be reevaluated
having said that it's much milder and we
have the other problem of
long covered and that is still in the
unvaccinated quite a
significant proportion of young people
about one percent are
getting debilitating symptoms at three
months that prevent them
going back to the normal function and
we're seeing
about 500 to 700 estimated cases a day
of that and that should be the parameter
that should be discussed
by the media not really deaths anymore
is the reason that you think we don't
need to focus on the death metric as
much now because you think that it's
going to be
one that stays low you think that and
that
aspect of the pandemic sadly you know
the worst
outcome that you would die from this
disease is one that is now more or less
under control
i do believe that yes i think deaths are
not going to go suddenly out of control
um there might be some other
deaths as we go into winter again as we
combine with flu
but i don't think this is going to be
worse than you know a bad flu winter
rather than anything else so as long as
we have a plan
to keep boost of vaccinations going
in the very vulnerable and that
occurs well and there's no major shifts
in the
in the variants then i'm
i'm not very worried about deaths as the
main outcome
and you're talking about long coverage
uh you know it's it's a very frightening
idea that one would be debilitated
um from having this virus for 10 days
two weeks and then you know potentially
have months if not a
a lifetime of consequences of that
but one of the problems is we just still
don't know a lot about long covet
exactly how one goes about
diagnosing it um you know what it means
for somebody if if they do receive that
diagnosis
is this because our priorities haven't
been in the right place for some time
and we haven't been putting enough
emphasis
on long covid or is this just generally
very difficult
to go about diagnosing and finding out
about viral fatigue that can come
from all sorts of viruses i think it's a
mixture of both
i think that you've got to realize that
with any new disease or new set of
symptoms it does
take usually years to try sorting them
out and working out
which which ones go with which
type of disease what the prognosis is
we really haven't got long term data
to to help us and also i think that
most governments around the world have
been focused on
deaths of their citizens as as the main
priority
and keeping the hospitals going rather
on this
longer term public health problem which
is what's going to be engaging people
from now on so
i think it's a combination of that lack
of priority uh
lack of setting up studies early on and
and the actual inherent difficulties in
studying something that
as you said does occur with with most
viruses to some extent
that there is a residual tail and
this is no exception and other than the
fact that
the symptoms are particularly striking
and and often very long lasting
so i think we do have a problem we do
need
a lot more data on this we're still very
deprived of it
and we don't know that all the effects
of
the immune boosters vaccinations on long
covered
we still haven't done some crucial
obvious studies in long covert
there should have now been a study of
steroids or dexamethasone
in this by now and it's it's it's
surprising that hasn't been done
and uh other methods haven't really been
tried so
i i think we're in a in a place now we
have to recognize this is
probably the you know one of the major
public health problems
that is going to have an impact on the
nhs and uh we need to
pay many more resources than we are
putting into it at the moment
well we already have uh five million
people on waiting lists the new health
secretary sajaba thinks it could go up
to 13 million in the coming months so
um certainly uh something that could
burden the health service further
if we take all of this into account
especially looking at what you call the
new phase taking into account
long covid as well what do you make of
the reopening that's been announced on
the 19th of july are you broadly in
favor of it or do you think that it's
too carefree i'm broadly in favor
i think there has to come a time when
you realize you can't keep people locked
up
and you can't keep telling everyone what
to do
and constraining their their liberties
and you have to balance that
the opening up with the benefits of the
economy
which has major health impacts and of
course
try and encourage people who have
preventable diseases from
not just staying at home with them but
actually coming and up to hospitals and
feeling that
they're safer to come out and uh get
treated
because um you know the the collateral
damage from people not getting cancer
treatments or
getting diagnosed uh horrendous really
because
already we had won the worst records in
europe for cancer and this is just going
to make it worse so
also realizing that with the phase of
the i think it signals
definite change in the phase of the
disease as we move
to pandemic to endemic
and there'll still be lots of disease
going around we're never going to get
zero covid
and we are moving to milder disease as
long as
people get vaccinated so i think that's
an important message
that this uh these lifting restrictions
which have been gradual
people seem to think it's all happening
on one day but it's not really the
google mobility data show that
you know people are back at about 85
percent of
uh normal anyway already now
so it's not like it's going from zero to
a hundred percent
and i think the only area i
i'm happy and i was unhappy with was
that
things like public transport and major
crowding
was not going to have any restrictions
at all and
it looks like that is now uh
you know wearing masks on crowded public
transport etc
is going to stay and i think that's that
is really important
just like you would in any you should do
probably in any major flu epidemic um
to try and control things so doing
things that don't harm the economy
uh that that make general sense uh
keeping those going i think is important
but
we've got to start to work out how we're
going to live with this virus not keep
running away from it
well that was going to be my last
question to you tim do you think
despite their willingness to move
forward with reopening
it's been confusing messaging from
government that on the one hand they're
promising freedom day
but at the same time they were
indicating to people that perhaps they
shouldn't use all of those freedoms and
they should still voluntarily take
many precautions or avoid crowded spaces
do you think
the messaging has been clear enough i
wouldn't
have used the same messaging the
government has and i think
people are confused and it will be that
some people will still be very
frightened to leave the house
and others will think that they can do
whatever they like
and i think this is this is a potential
danger
so i would like to see better messaging
that this virus is going to be with us
for years
that we should be looking for cold-like
symptoms because we're infecting each
other because the government is still
not
putting itself on the line and saying
actually things have changed
and that the five common symptoms are
just like having a bad cold headache
sore throat
runny nose sneeze
these are really important to get that
message across
as well as saying in a crowded place if
you're feeling unwell
you know the same precautions should
should carry on but let's try and get
back to normal
and i think it's it's they need to
realize that people need their education
you can't treat them
like sheep all the time and i think
giving them the latest information
that's what being trying to do
with the zoe app all the time and i
think
that would be my message to the
government is to give people the facts
tell them what the symptoms are so tell
them what their actual risks are
and let them get back to normal and that
people make their own
decisions to some extent but they should
be safe to go on public transport for
example
tim thanks for joining me now the big
news in politics this week strangely
hasn't been monday's reopening but a
proposed and now confirmed
cut to the foreign aid budget in his
politics column for the magazine this
week james forsyth
says it's a march of the unwipables to
explain and to talk about the latest in
politics
james joins me alongside our assistant
editor isabel hardman
james in your piece you say it's a sign
of the battles to come in the rest
of this parliament can you explain
yes so you had the government majority
was in the end fairly comfortable you
still had 24 tory mps voting against a
three-line whip
and 14 of them are former ministers
and i think one of the issues that the
government whips are going to face in
in in the coming years is that these 14
are uninterested in return to office or
only interested in return to office on
their own terms they are
essentially unwipable and that is going
to be a challenge because
there will be i think the 0.7 vote was
difficult vote it was a breaking
manifesto commitment
but it's not the most difficult vote the
government is going to face in this
parliament you know
there will be more difficult votes on
planning on social care
possibly on vaccine passports and
there'll be more difficult questions
about you know how much money to spend
on dealing with the nhs waiting list how
do you in the spending review divide up
the
resources between the nhs criminal
justice system
education and i think that the
government is going into those votes
with uh a small but significant
unwipable bunch of mps who are former
ministers
i also think that there are you know
there are the department story
parliamentary party is
is not as disciplined as it once was
just look at the fact that later on
on tuesday first utility mps voted
against plans to make it compulsory for
uh
workers in social and care homes to have
had the kobe vaccine unless there's a
medical reason why they should not
isabel theresa may was the most high
profile mp to vote against
the government here's what she had to
say in her speech
this isn't about palaces for dictators
and vanity projects
it's about what cuts to funding mean
that fewer girls will be educated
more girls and boys will become slaves
more children will go hungry
and more of the poorest people in the
world will die
now the government has promised what
they see as a compromise i'm grateful to
the chancellor for speaking to me
last night i asked uh how long it would
take before the tests are met
and we was turned to 0.7 i was told four
to five years but it could be sooner
because the economy is recovering so
well
now if the motion is defeated tonight
it'd be 0.7
from january next year the government
appears to be saying to us
we can't afford 0.7 next year because
the economy is doing so badly
but actually the economy is doing so
well that we could very well be able to
restore 0.7 very soon
but the government can't have it both
ways
how serious a threat does this new group
pose to the government
it was quite a forceful speech from the
former prime minister actually on
on the day that marked five years since
she'd become
prime minister she chose to celebrate it
by accusing the government
of taking a decision that would ensure
that uh
some more of the poorest people in the
world
would die which is uh is quite a threat
just in terms of the sort of
the projection of the conservative brand
more widely
you know theresa may as a former prime
minister
she did leave in um not on her own terms
and i think her authority therefore is
slightly different to someone
for instance say tony blair who is still
making interventions on uk politics
from quite a position of strength i
think um but
the way in which she and as james says
are other
senior mps very experienced very
knowledgeable
not just in the way that westminster and
whitehall works but also in the way that
parliament works and the way they can
use parliament
it is a big threat that they pose to to
the government because
they know how to land big lines against
ministers they know how to
work with colleagues on rebellions um
anders james says that
they're just not interested in in
promotion at any cost so you can't buy
them off with the promise of some job
even if boris johnson does want to do a
reshuffle soon which i suspect is
becoming
less and less attractive to him for
exactly this reason because you'll end
up turfing out
more senior people from the cabinets
who then think well i've got nothing to
lose i might as well even if
even if they're not angry with boris
johnson they think i might as well
uh become more of a sort of scrutineer
on the back benches rather than a
compliant person who
who wants to be promoted and to use
james's phrase
these unwipables put the government's
majority into perspective
it may be a relatively small group but
at times it could be a powerful one
isabel i noted that only one mp from the
2019
intake voted against the cuts and the
government
what lesson can we learn from that
well i think there are still a lot of
mps who would quite like to be promoted
but i thought one thing that was
interesting was that the
whips clearly weren't rattled enough by
the prospect of losing this vote that
they sent
out a load of eager recently elected mps
who will basically give a supportive
speech of the government
on anything no matter how embarrassing
the position is for
ministers we didn't really have that in
this week's debates
and i think had we had that it would
have been a sign that the whips thought
the numbers on this rebellion
were much tighter than they ended up
being
james is the prime minister ultimately
trying to hold a coalition together
that perhaps doesn't have a very happy
future
i i think the tory party has become more
of a national party than it has been at
any point in in our lifetimes but that
obviously brings
challenges with it in that you've you're
you're representing some very different
seats
i think one of the things we're going to
see okay is that the
british politics is going to become more
american in a sense in that
you in the way that you used to have
blue dog democrats who represented you
know southern seats who had a distinct
interest and and voice compared to the
rest of the party or new england
republicans who are very different from
the sun belt or southern members of the
gop i think you will begin to get that
in the tory party i think one of the
things that you've seen
post the cheshire american bar election
when the dems overturned a 16
000 tory majority is you've got southern
tory mps wondering whether they need a
kind of southern research group to kind
of match the northern
research group and so i think you will
see more
uh tory mps forming more factions
coalitions within the party
and i think the argument will become
that you hold together that
internal coalition so you don't have to
build an external coalition
because it is also worth remembering the
tory party is essentially
uncoalitionable
in that if there is a home parliament
over the next election
i don't see any potential coalition
partners for the tories
so they really do need to win outright
in a way that labour doesn't
well speaking of american imports the
culture wars are also a politically
hot topic this week isabel there's
trouble brewing in the conservative
party about their reaction to racist
abuse directed at england players
after their loss to italy in the euros
this weekend
this got bad for the government when
pretty patel said she was disgusted at
the abuse but then tyrone mings an
england defender replied
saying the home secretary had stoked the
fire at the beginning of the tournament
by saying that taking the knee before
games
was gesture politics it's not a great
look for the conservative government
is it no and partly this is because if
you're going to pick a fight you need to
think about who you're going to have
a fight with i mean people who i've
never had a physical fight but people
who have physical fights tend to pick it
with people who they think they can beat
rather than somebody who's you know two
foot taller than them
and uh can regularly i don't know pull
fire engines with one hand
and i think this is the this is the sort
of uh the the comparison between the
conservatives and
uh footballers in that we know and have
known for a very long time
that footballers are more popular than
politicians and so if you're going to
pick a fight with footballers
then you're quite brave i think you're
very brave to pick a fight with
this bunch of footballers in the england
team because they are so likable
and the way in which they justified
their decision to take the knee which
you know the scottish team didn't do
was very uh muted they didn't do it in a
sort of
here we are we're joining the culture
wars and you know we want to defund the
police
their argument was that this was just a
way of them saying that they stood
against racism and that they respected
one another
and it was a mark of respect and it
should have been quite difficult to
argue with that but for some reason i
think the
taking the near has become one of those
things that just triggers
conservative mps and they cannot resist
getting involved in a fight
regardless of who it's with and so we
had lee anderson
saying he wasn't going to watch the
games as though that was you know really
going to be the thing that would crush
the england team and then pretty patel
and boris johnson
suggesting that taking the knee was
gesture politics
now i suppose it is gesture politics but
then that's how humans
interact with each other that's how we
show respect we wear
a poppy which is a gesture as a gesture
of respect
for the fallen and you know we we tend
to defend
that gesture against people who say that
it i don't know supports war mongering
or
all that sort of thing um so the tories
are well-versed in
defending gesture politics uh when it's
something that they
uh agree with and surely they would want
to
agree with fighting racism now they
don't agree with defunding the police
and so on but i think they've got
so caught up in the sort of academic
debates around
who owns the gesture of taking the knee
whether it's black lives matter whether
it's
you know other fringe groups or whether
it's
the england football team showing a mark
of respect that they've forgotten
what most people will see it as which is
that gesture of respect
well this has been a thoughtful and
nuanced conversation with james and
me so far isabelle so i don't think
we're going to be pulling you into your
first
physical brawl today um james you've
said before that the tories are trying
to
pick culture war battles where they
think they can win
have they misjudged this one yeah i
think boris johnson's approach for
cultural wars has typically been to wait
for the other side to
overreach and then respond so uh in
the whole great statute debate he waited
until people
started until some fringe voices started
talking about pulling down
taking down churchill statue and then he
could have waded in to defend him now
i think the vast majority of people
share that position so it's a fairly
safe position to do it you know you
could you might notice that when
clive of india's statue uh was being
discussed you didn't see boris johnson
kind of racing to the front of the queue
to get
into that debate i i mean the problem
that they have got into
is the one that isabelle describes which
is getting into a row of football team
before a major international tournament
is a mistake
in that as that football team does well
uh you are you are
you know the country just wants to get
behind them and i think it was also
right about
that you've got to distinguish between
two things
the england football team are clearly
not doing it
to endorse the entirety of the black
lives matter political agenda
on you know defunding the police the
attacks on the nuclear family and all of
that
and so while while you can see why they
don't want to take the need themselves
attacking those who do
what i think i think has ended up
putting them in in a difficult position
i think you saw at pmq's on wednesday
how uncomfortable boris johnson was when
asked about
you know priti patel basically refusing
to to condemn those people who
who booed it as as a gesture
and so i think that is the difficulty i
mean one of the challenges of the tory
party is
you know look the obviously the biggest
risk to boris johnson's apprenticeship
right now
is what happens after the july 19th
reopening you know
is there sufficient hospital capacity
but these issues
around um taking the knee and the like
are not going to go away over the next
few years
i think they talk about he needs to find
a
better place to express its opinions on
this
and i think it is it is in some ways
very old but they've got themselves
tangled up in such a mess
when they have by far the most diverse
cabinet
uh in in in british history and actually
a far more diverse cabinet than most
other
uh western democracies i think things
are also made
more difficult for the government if we
go back to where taking the knee first
originated it wasn't part
of the black lives matter movement or a
particular political
association it was colin kaepernick
another sports figure over in the states
in american football
who took the need to protest racial
discrimination in america so
that camaraderie between sports players
isn't really coming from a
political entity it's coming from a far
more emotional one
isabel last question to you how do they
go about fixing this
steve baker said on wednesday that the
party is in danger of misrepresenting
its own heart for those who suffer
injustice
well i think they have tried to change
their tune since the racist abuse of
the england players in the aftermath of
sunday's
final i think there has been an attempt
uh from
ministers to obviously to condemn the
racism but also to show they're taking
racism very seriously by hauling in the
social media companies by
trying to instigate uh bans for
fans who are found to be hurling racist
abuse whether it's online or in person
and so on and so that there is a push
within government to appear to be taking
this seriously but obviously
it does appear a little bit uh panicked
in the last minute
and so as with all uh things in politics
it needs to be sustained
once the news cycle moves on rather than
thinking right we've ticked the
anti-racist box now we're absolutely
fine
let's move on james and isabel thanks
for joining me
now to cuba where protests across the
island are posing a serious challenge to
the socialist leadership
why the protest now how is the regime
reacted
and will supporters of socialism around
the world finally criticize the cuban
government
i'm joined by chris sabatini a senior
fellow at chatham house who specializes
in the politics of latin america
chris thanks for joining us on spectator
tv to start
are these protests just a reaction to
the consequences of the pandemic or
something bigger happening
these are long-standing demands and
grievances the cuban people have had i
mean obviously the pandemic has worsened
them
first of all because of the lack of
access to medicine and the collapsed
healthcare system cuba is often
celebrated
for its revolution in health care but
the truth is it's it's fallen apart
long ago it's deeply romanticized and
now pretty much a myth and
so what you're seeing is people's
reaction to that but also the economy is
crumbled in 2020
the economy contracted by 11 percent and
that's
largely uh because of the restrictions
on kovid
that led to the tourism uh declining
dropping off almost entirely not just
from the united states because of the
embargo but from
the europe from europe from latin
america from canada
um but also the economy itself is just
it's just creaking along it's a
tired old communist system that's
failing to produce enough food for the
people has to import most of its food
and as the economy and the country try
to unify its very complicated
dual exchange rate just last year that
led to a spike in the prices of
imported food so people were
experiencing both shortages and high
prices in most of the
dollar or foreign currency exchange
stores so between health care
between lack of access to food out right
hunger to be perfectly honest in
malnutrition
and just desperation that's what we're
seeing expressed now but obviously covid
was probably the tipping point at least
in terms of
the healthcare concerns of covid and the
government is of course blaming the
united states but the protesters simply
aren't buying it
yeah of course they're blaming the
united states and they would uh you know
they can't admit their own failures and
so they
go to the traditional straw man of
blaming the u.s embargo and the embargo
may be a clumsy
policy tool personally i think that's
the case but uh it's not the reason
whether
why there are shortages or why the
economy has failed or or even
why the health care system is falling
apart but and they're also believing the
united states
alleging that it supported the
protesters but you need only look at the
number of
cities in which people have taken to the
streets across
cuba uh and realized that this can't be
orchestrated from anyone or anywhere but
also
the nature of the protests themselves
these people aren't demanding
necessarily regime change although
that's an element of it given the
brittleness of the regime and its lack
of accountability
they're really demanding just basic
goods uh you know bread and butter
issues
and that's really what's driving this
and for that reason this is really cuts
to the quick
for the cuban government i mean it's
failed to provide for its people this is
a revolution that sort of sustained
itself
largely on the myth but sustained itself
on the idea that it's a revolution that
provides for the poor
and it simply can't tolerate the idea
that suddenly those people are taking
the streets and denouncing the
government and their own
and announcing to the world their own uh
basic needs
one interesting thing by the way about
the the protest if you look at the
videos
what you see is these are not you know
the traditional human rights activists
and dissidents
uh that have often been you know if you
will
sort of uh part of uh us discussion and
dialogue on these issues
largely these are afro-descendant cubans
people who who
would have uh decades ago claim to have
benefited from the revolution are now
taking the streets
so this really goes to the very heart of
the revolution in its own
failings so in his piece for the
spectator this week rory says
this sort of thing just doesn't happen
in cuba and you're
hinting at that as well that something
feels really different this time
compared to how it's been in the past
yeah i would say there are a couple of
things that are different uh within the
island okay
uh the first is that we see again
the socio-economic differences of this
of this uh just in terms of the people
on the streets their racial composition
their age uh multi-sectoral as i
mentioned it's artists it's artisans
it's it's
a small entrepreneurs the second thing
that's different about this
is their coordination by social media
and and this is unheard of
you're seeing uh for the first time
people plan
and and organize facebook events um
share videos of crackdowns but also
protesters
which is added to a certain element of
courage people are sort of saying we're
not afraid that's what they're saying
and this is very much in the article
that you mentioned the spectator and
that's important
people suddenly they feel empowered
social media is at their fingertips
uh and we've seen of course as you would
expect the cuban government just tried
to shut down the internet
um it can't entirely but it's trying to
nip this in the bud
there's uh two other things that make
this important another one is i
mentioned is that this is about bread
and butter issues
uh yes it's about freedom yes it's about
human rights
yes it's about denouncing the regime but
it really is about socioeconomics
at its heart and that's unique in many
ways and i think it's a very powerful
message
there's one last thing that's very
important about this is
as media has become more savvy and
international
as the regime has had to tolerate
some pushes by the international
community to open up in some ways
marginally we now have a really good
cohort of
international correspondents that are on
the ground as well as
working with independent journalists
from cuba in cuba
on the ground reporting on this so in
this case uh what we're seeing is that
the the actions of these people are
being broadcast through social media
through traditional media but also
through local media um independent
journalists as i mentioned like gianni
sanchez and others are posting this and
blogging about it and reporting it in
live
time but they're also reporting on the
crackdown that we've seen
there are pictures of bloodied one
person has died a bloodied photographer
from the ap
this is going to be very very powerful
powerful because often in the past
the numbers of journalists that space
has been very limited and consequently
they've been able the
basically the regime has been able to
repress with impunity
well you mentioned at the start of this
interview that many of the reasons that
protesters have taken to the streets or
that they are disappointed with what is
quite frankly
a failed uh socialist regime
and as you point out there's a lot of
international attention on
this now because the press from very
local press to the international press
is giving it quite rightly that
attention i've noticed that a lot of
voices who would often be sympathetic to
those ideas
and in the international community in
western countries are
oddly silent on this one do you think
they're going to have to pipe up and
make a comment on it at some point
you know i'm not sure about that again
lenin referred to people like that as
useful idiots for the revolution they
sort of unwittingly enabled or complied
with uh
revolution and the denial of people's
rights um i think it's gonna be very
difficult for some people to part with
the myth and the romanticization of of
the castros
uh of uh the regime i'd like to believe
that but you know having worked on cuba
for a long time
and having uh experienced and tried to
mobilize uh people to react to
uh crackdowns in the past for example
the the this
black spring of 2003 i i've just been
astounded by the double standards and
hypocrisy of of
people who are willing to denounce human
rights abuses say in chile under
pinochet
um and then just suddenly shy away from
doing so in cuba and i
i suspect that may that may be the case
i mean there are a few i think that will
start to speak out michelle bachelet
who's a high commissioner for human
rights at the un has been very shy about
speaking out before on cuba in fact
it's alleged i haven't confirmed this
that she has never personally spoken out
on human rights abuses in cuba i think
it's going to be very difficult for them
to do that but i think other people a
number of academics
journalists and like artists are going
to be a little bit
reticent to do that and it's a shame
because whereas in the past
maybe they could try to fool themselves
maybe when a castro was in power they
could claim that this
was you know this was the mantle of a
revolutionary leader and they're still
beholden to all those myths of the
revolution but now it's post-castro
and the images are clear not just of the
crackdown but also the people that are
on the streets
uh but i honestly i hate to sound
cynical i don't have any great faith in
people
that before i've been silent uh suddenly
speaking up
yeah and i'm i'm gonna be cynical along
there with you
and i'm also gonna ask you a very broad
question so forgive me in advance but
i'm just so curious
about how the political attitudes are
shifting in cuba
now you know we want to avoid
stereotypes because like any other
country you're going to have a broad
spectrum
of political opinion but in relation to
these protests i mean
if they were to have some success what
would that success look like and what
are the new political demands that are
growing
in cuba and and is there a divide
between say the younger generations and
the older generations that might be
slightly more sympathetic to the regime
well it's a good question and it's
difficult as you say because
cuba is diverse it's large it's a
country of 11 million people
um i i just tell a few anecdotes about
this because i think they're
illustrative
one time i was in cuba i was having
dinner with a group of young
people not necessarily activists they
were just uh university of havana
students that like young professionals
and i asked them you know what do you
what do you think because by way of
context most people in cuba recognize
uh the failings of the regime they they
recognize and they'll speak
quietly and in hush tones uh about
um you know the need for change but they
don't really want to speak out and i
asked these young cubans
what do you hope for and almost to a
person they said we hope to leave
we have no future here and that's very
difficult and what's interesting now
is suddenly is that sense of desperation
that lack of of hope
may suddenly be being challenged to the
street rather than an effort to flee
and that's positive and i think once you
build that once you build that sense of
of hope then you get what what your
article says as people start to speak
about
the lack of fear they're not as afraid
uh and i think that's very very
important in terms of
pockets of support for the regime you
know it's very difficult to tell of
course there are people in the
government
who very much support support the regime
but you never know
i mean as i when i teach at columbia
university
i would tell my students you know try
and describe what it's like in cuba and
the conversations you have privately
with people
you know imagine working in an office
where the same boss has been in power
for 60 years
how frustrating would that be you know
that person just
personally controls everything that
happens in the office and it depends on
on his whim uh would not be a work
environment that you'd want to work in
so we don't even know within the
government how much they support this
and lastly is one other element to this
which is very different
which is there's not a caster on power
right now last year raul castro stepped
down for the presidency of the
communist party before that he stepped
down from the presidency of the country
and this is going to be important
because you know you don't have that
myth of the revolution again you don't
have
the the cadre of guerrilleros guerrillas
that were around
fidel well castro empower anymore it's a
new generation and they lack
that legitimacy that sort of
revolutionary cred if you will
and consequently what you've heard from
diaz canel miguel diaz-canel the
president
is he's going to respond in a
revolutionary manner what he's saying is
i'm no different than the casters i'm
going to respond
the same way with an iron fist and it's
a message not just to the people
and he's called them as revolutionaries
to the streets it's also a message to
those around him saying
i'm not going to give up don't we we're
not we're not going
forward this is the same old regime and
i'm abiding by our
cafe maximo our chief leader the now
deceased fidel castro
chris thanks for coming on the show
finally if you had one ticket to the
euro final
would you go or would you stay home to
watch the game with your kid
toby young is coming on the show now to
talk about his time at wembley
toby in your column this week you say
you failed a moral test at the weekend
what happened so i was trying to get
two tickets for the euro 2020
final at wembley and one for me one for
my 13 year old son who is my
football buddy and and i couldn't
so we were resigned to watching it
together at home and then a friend of
mine called up and said
did i want a ticket but he only had one
so the moral test was
do i turn it down and watch the game
at home with my son or do i accept the
ticket
and in about a nanosecond i accepted the
ticket
um and i felt quite guilty about it and
spent quite a lot of time trying to kind
of
rationalize it to myself you know if my
son's friend had offered him a ticket i
expect he would have accepted
you know opportunities to see england in
the final of an international tournament
only come along once every 55 years i
wouldn't forgive myself if i missed this
my dad went to the
1966 world cup final at wembley so i
feel like i ought to be at this one
and so on and so forth but it did mean
that when i went to the game my
conscience was
gnawing away at me throughout so did
your
son accept your argument and your point
of view that it just runs in the family
that
fathers go to uh finals alone
um i i'm not sure whether he's accepted
it yet
um he says that he doesn't mind and
doesn't blame me and didn't want me to
turn it down but i think only time will
tell whether he really has forgiven me
yeah toby it's the kind of thing you'll
find out on his wedding day he's still
holding on to when his wedding speech
only centers on that one topic but as
you say in your piece perhaps it was
good that your son wasn't there talk to
us about what it was like at wembley
well it was all pretty hairy
particularly getting in
so as me and my two companions arrived
hundreds of fans broke through the metal
barrier which you had to kind of stand
outside in order to
show your covert pass as you then enter
the kind of perimeter of the stadium so
they broke through this barrier
and stormed through the handicap
entrance of
wembley and then stormed into the
stadium ticketless fans
and and then um other fans took
advantage of the chaos in the wake of
this
barrier break to swarm through the
barriers themselves and
around all the gated entrances and
people were kind of
queueing up they were shoved out of the
way in some cases people holding
phones because everyone had their
tickets downloaded on their phones
had their phones snatched out of their
hands so these ticketless fans could
then get past the turnstiles and
into the grounds and into seats it was
really chaotic and
even as we got through the turnstile
ourselves um
my my companion was knocked over in a
sort of malay as
there was a sort of mass brawl like a
scene in a kind of western bar
between these kind of marauding
hooligans and the wembley stewards the
police were nowhere in sight
and my friend got knocked over and he
lost his phone in the process and
someone immediately grabbed it and
started running away
at which point another fan rugby tackled
the thief and then he was able to get
his phone
back but it was like if my 13 year old
son had been there i'm not sure
um it would have been ideal you know i
would have been very concerned not just
about protecting my phone but about
protecting my son as well i mean it was
it wasn't really a suitable occasion for
families to be honest
no it doesn't sound like a family
occasion at all and the more reports
that are coming out it seems like
security
uh was just not prepared for what they
were actually going to be
facing i mean did you feel safe when you
were there did you feel like the
security was lacking
it felt as though the security was set
up so if you
had a covered pass and you had a ticket
it was incredibly difficult to get into
the stadium
but if you hadn't bothered to get
vaccinated or taken a lateral flow test
and you didn't have a ticket
there was nothing to prevent you kind of
rushing into the stadium it was you know
for law-abiding citizens it was
unbelievably torturous
and lengthy the process to get in but if
you were a hooligan
you know you just waltzed on it it was
it was it was really poorly
uh uh uh um uh arranged managed and
there were some police there but um they
were completely overwhelmed and
outnumbered i don't think they were
expecting
so many fans to converge on wembley
stadium i mean
maybe it was a silly idea to hold it at
eight o'clock in the evening given that
then
a lot of fans would have been drinking
all day and a lot of the people kind of
running amok
in the stadium without tickets trying to
steal people's phones were clearly drunk
yeah oh gosh i mean to be honest um well
i desperately wish i had been there it
sounds like maybe maybe i'm glad i
wasn't
um the game started well enough anyway
was all your anxiety swept away within
two minutes when luke shaw put away that
goal
yeah no i wouldn't say it was i mean i i
um you know as soon as
we put the kind of um mayhem behind us
and settled into our seats we then kind
of became
really anxious about what was in front
of us which was you know
um the first international tournament
final
england's been in for 55 years and you
know football's
nerve-wracking enough at the best of
times when the stakes are that
high it becomes almost unbearably tense
um and um i think if england had got a
goal you know
in the second half or even on you know
uh just before half time
that would have done something to
relieve the tension but getting a goal
so quickly and then
sitting back in our own half and sort of
inviting the italians to attack our goal
and doing our best to defend it that
actually just ratcheted up the anxiety
and i became
absolutely convinced that the italians
were going to equalise and then as soon
as they did equalize i thought well
that's it
it's going to penalties it was always
going to go to penalties
and we're going to lose the penalty
shootout as we always do it seemed like
a kind of
the tragedy of english football playing
itself out in front of us and there was
just
nothing you could do about it i mean the
fans were willing the team to succeed
roaring them on applauding the slightest
exhibition of talent uh but kind of
knowing in their heart of hearts all
sixty 000 of us that there was really
nothing we could do
to escape the kind of ghost of england
football past and you know if it came to
a penalty shootout we'd just be bound to
lose because we always do
there was this kind of you know naive
belief that because it was a young
team and they seemed so optimistic and
well managed
by gareth southgate that they would be
able to kind of cast off
these demons you know they wouldn't be
haunted by the ghost of summer's past
you know would they be able to bring
football home uh but actually
turned out when it came down to it uh in
the penalty shootout
suddenly the ghosts were there on the
pitch kind of on the player's shoulders
whispering in their ears
and and of course they they fluffed it
well our viewers are painfully aware of
how that story
ended this is my last question to you do
you think the disappointment of losing
and the messiness at wembley was worth
the joys of beating germany
winning against denmark in extra time
and making it to the first final in over
50 years
yeah it was um it was a fantastic
tournament and
um you know a huge um uh tonic
after 16 months of kind of misery
and i enjoyed i enjoyed it i mean i
couldn't i didn't quite enter into
i wasn't as enthusiastic about it as i
might have been and i wrote about that
in the spectator a few weeks ago
i had various reservations about the
kind of
progressive strain running through the
england setup
and the kind of various gestures they
were making including taking the knee
which i wasn't particularly
enthusiastic about i wanted them to to
come together with another less
divisive um way of signaling their
support for the cause of anti-racism
other than taking the knee which is so
indelibly wrapped up with black lives
matter but you know
i got i got you know i i i got beyond
that and when we scored
you know when kane scored the winning
goal against denmark suddenly i was all
in and just
hoping against hope that we'd win
um but you know it's the hope that kills
you toby
thanks for joining us and that's all for
this week
if you enjoyed this episode why not
subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel so you never miss out
just click the subscribe button at the
bottom of this video and the bell icon
to make sure you never
miss an episode thanks again for
watching the show
and do join us again next week on
spectator tv
[Music]
you